أود أن أعود بك إلى أهم
قصتنا ، فالفوضى في القدس قبل
جنازة صحفية الجزيرة
شيرين أبو أطلا هرعت الشرطة الإسرائيلية
وضربت المعزين الذين كانوا يحملون
نعشها أتيكا شوبرت وشاهدت كل
هذا يتكشف في القدس لنا وهي
تنضم إلينا  لقد قلنا الآن أن
هذه لقطات مروعة
حقًا نشاهدها والعديد من الأشخاص يسألون عن
سبب قيام الشرطة الإسرائيلية
بضرب الأشخاص الذين يحملون النعش على
سبيل المثال.
استقطاب للمشاهدة
وصعب مشاهدته ،
من الصعب جدًا مشاهدته ، أعتقد أن
ما يجب أن تفهمه هو أن
الذهاب إلى اليوم كان
هناك الكثير من المشاعر والتوتر بالفعل
بالأمس ، خرج آلاف الأشخاص
في موجة من الحزن و  لذلك كانت
هذه الأرقام متوقعة وفي
الواقع ظهرت اليوم ولكن في
المستشفى
قالت الشرطة الإسرائيلية إنها
لن تسمح لها ولأسرتها بجنازة على الأقدام
كان هناك محاولة
لتقرير ما إذا كانوا سيمضون
قدمًا في موكب الجنازة التقليدية
أو ما إذا كانوا
سينقلون الجثة بالسيارة ،
ما حدث في النهاية هو أن
المعزين الذين كانوا هناك رفضوا
نقله بالسيارة ، كان هناك هذا
الارتفاع العام.  لجعله موكب جنازة سيرا على الأقدام ،
لذلك عندما
أحضروا التابوت إلى بوابات المستشفى ،
أوقفتهم شرطة مكافحة الشغب الإسرائيلية ثم
اتهموا موكب الجنازة بالدخول
إلى أرض المستشفى ، أطلقوا
ما لا يقل عن قنبلتين صوتيتين وغاز مسيل للدموع
وكذلك ما رأيناه كان  أن شرطة مكافحة الشغب هذه
كانت تمتلك هراوات وقد قاموا في الواقع
بضرب بعض حاملي النعش في
وقت ما مما تسبب في انزلاق
التابوت تقريبًا على الأرض
، كما تم استخدام شرطة مكافحة الشغب الموجودة على صهوة الجياد لشن هجوم عبر
الشوارع المحيطة بالمستشفى لتفريق
البعض  من المعزين هناك كان
مشهدًا فوضويًا تمامًا ،
وبعد ذلك حدث تهدئة الأمور
ولكن الأسرة كانت قادرة على  o أحضر التابوت
أخيرًا إلى الكنيسة في المدينة القديمة
، الكنيسة الكاثوليكية اليونانية هناك
، وتمكنوا من نقله بالسيارة
ومن هناك سمحت الشرطة الإسرائيلية
للجماهير بالحضور فعليًا من الكنيسة
وإحضار التابوت إلى المقبرة
الآلاف والآلاف من
اتضح أن المشهد كان مذهلاً
لكل هؤلاء الأشخاص وهم يتدفقون
من الحزن على شخص كان بالنسبة لكثير من
الفلسطينيين يشبه تقريبًا عضوًا ممتدًا
من العائلة ، كانت
شيرين أبو آه أكثر من مجرد
صحفية مخضرمة لأنها أبلغت
عن سبب عدم تأريخها.  العديد من
الفلسطينيين هي حياتهم اليومية في ظل
الاحتلال الإسرائيلي ،
فقد كانت في غرف معيشتهم كل يوم
تنقل الأخبار وهذا هو السبب في أن
الكثير من الفلسطينيين يمثلون
خسارة شخصية وعاطفية للغاية
لك.